so Joe I don't you know there's kind of
somewhere around seven eight nine ten
thousand astrophysicists in the world
and about what are we have two seven
eight billion people if you divide those
two numbers an astrophysicist is one in
a million in the world whoa so if you're
ever in the same room with one that's
when you need to ask all the questions
you just never know the next chance
that's coming do you have any questions
that you've been harboring your whole
life about the universe that you can ask
right now yes well I was thinking just
before that I wonder if it's the same
amount as comedians like professional
comedians I bet it's really similar okay
however comedians as a practice are
always in front of many people yes
you're being a comedian you are in front
of tons of people right being a
scientist we're never in front of
anybody so access to comedians I think
is much higher than access to scientists
to astrophysicist yeah but those I bet
those numbers could be the same they're
pretty close yeah so here's my question
the concept of the multiverse you know
the concept of alternative universes
with alternative laws of physics is
incredibly puzzling to me mm-hmm
now when you think about the idea that
this could be reality that there could
be other universes with different laws
of physics there could be an infinite
number of these different laws of
physics and different does that how does
that work okay so it's an excellent
question
we think when I say we just the
scientific community physicists who
concern themselves with the very early
universe cosmologists that the laws of
physics as we experience them are set in
the very earliest stages of the universe
and quantum fluctuations in everything
would be responsible for another
universe having slightly different laws
of physics than ours because the quantum
fluctuations will take it in a slightly
different law of physics direction than
our universe and this would just keep
going every universe that's born even if
it started out sort of the same in the
very first instant a later instant when
other laws of physics manifest could be
slightly different and with the
multiverse where there could be pockets
of the universe that are expanding with
no knowledge of any other pockets of the
universe these are essentially
independent universes from one another
and never the twain will meet imagine
your ship at sea and you look to the
horizon and that's your whole universe
they are to the horizon there's another
ship that has his own horizon and you
declare this is the universe and these
ships don't even see each other okay
you'll only see each other if somehow
you your two horizons can overlap and we
don't know how to do that in our
universe because they're non what's its
called non-causal all right you can't we
don't know how to you'd have to find
some way to tunnel from one universe to
the other in order to access access that
but that could be very dangerous because
if the laws of physics are different
then the ones you evolved on then you
could just dissolve into a pile of goo
because the charge on the electron is
different and all of your biochemistry
would change so the difference in laws
of physics comes about because of
quantum physics and the and the the
there's a I'm going to call it random
it's it's random but predictable so in
other words you can have a variation in
the properties of something and because
of the quantum fluctuations that exist
within it and when that's happening in
the early universe you are quantum
fluctuating the laws of physics
themselves and that's how you get one
universe with a slightly different law
of physics laws of physics than the
other there could be a there could be a
universe where
the laws of physics there will never
allow matter to coalesce you'll never
get stars that would be a lifeless
universe far as we can think there could
be another universe we can make stars
but you don't make heavy elements that
would be a universe with stars and
beautiful night skies as we have now but
no nothing that we know and love no
planets no life nothing because our
ingredients come from the Centers of
stars that explode the manufacturers
these the whole periodic table of
elements
where does that come from exploding
stars okay so so you can imagine other
universes that are not our universe
there could be universes way cooler than
ours universes where they formed life
way faster than ours did okay we didn't
have enough ingredients to make life
until we can make a planet every time a
star blows up and it has these heavy
elements it's not enough the first round
you got to accumulate them and we're
like second or third generation
supernova here in our solar system and
only then you get enough to have oxygen
carbon nitrogen silicon iron
we got enough we got a solid planet so
there's more than one supernova has to
take place before enough element more
than one generations of supernova yeah
you can add up how much that is and it's
feeding the entire galaxy so meeting
stars two supernova and then a new stars
to form and then correct correct so you
need a couple you need a few of those
generations to get enough density of
non-original star material to make
things like make a whole balls of
planets for example is it possibly even
so it's not very much material as big as
Saturn and Jupiter are they're made of
mostly gas mostly hydrogen and helium
that were made in the Big Bang not made
in stars
is it possible that there's something
else that could be invented or created
rather when more generations of
supernovas occur that haven't hasn't
happened yet like it took so many
generations for entrace to very
interesting so we are the product of the
mixtures of ingredients that are in this
universe
if you rank the elements in your body
the number one element is hydrogen
contained in the water molecule because
we're mostly water as you may remember
from biology the next most common atom
is oxygen from the water molecule third
most is carbon and we carbon-based life
fourth most is nitrogen well wait a
minute those are the top four
ingredients in the universe itself in
order sorry
not including helium which is chemically
inert you couldn't use it anyway
so it's the top four chemically active
ingredients in the you know we're made
of that so you ask a brilliant question
is there some other universe that is a
different mixture of other ingredients
and they opportunistically made stuff
out of those other ingredients what
would they be well that's a great
question I haven't never thought about
that but would a universe be like if it
was mostly molybdenum or some things
pick it up pick some elements pick some
random other four set of elements and
see what you can come up with
you need some chemical activity in it
carbon is highly reactive with other
elements so that's good it's not an
accident they were carbon-based we think
other life elsewhere in the universe
would be carbon-based because carbon is
plentiful and it bonds in so many
different ways if you're experimenting
with the diversity of life carbon is
your element to do that on so so this
this urge to say let's see if you have
silicon base life you sure because
silicon sits right below carbon on the
periodic table it makes all the same
kinds of molecules you're at a carbon
dioxide co2 there's silicon dioxide sio2
it makes the same families of molecules
so you can why not make like with sure
maybe but there's five times as much
carbon in the universe of silicon you
don't have to appeal to silicon carbon
is there knocking on your door
so for me my what's curious to me is the
assertion that if we have a multiverse
and there's an infinite number of
universes that means there's an infinite
combinations of all things that had ever
happened ever that there's another pair
of us having this conversation in
another universe except you're wearing a
bread shirt and I'm
whatever I mean you make tiny changes in
what is and say that's happening in one
other universe somewhere and people are
wondering is does this give you
immortality if you exist in this other
universe is that really you if your
entire molecular structure is identical
is that really you and I think people
are overstepping their I don't think
it's really you it's a copy of you but
it's not you and my evidence for that is
when you if you're a twin you don't wake
up as your twin ever mmm even though you
were molecular ly identical to each
other from birth you're not you don't
share each other's conscious so one of
you is an exact replica of the other
except you're not the same human beings
so I can make an exact replica of you
somewhere else but I don't think you'll
know or care it'll feel it so this talk
of I will live forever even when you
upload your consciousness through and we
don't understand consciousness enough to
know what makes you you and me me why
don't why do I wake up is me every day
and not as you or as anybody else that's
my that's consciousness can that be
carbon copied and blue or carbon copy
can that be duplicated and put somewhere
else and that still be you we're just
making a twin there's a whole other
independent consciousness that's what
keeps me up at night but it's but the
this is this concept of different laws
of physics is all from the quantum I
think it's gonna keep me up at night too
hahaha thanks Joe question my pleasure
this this has been Startalk one on one
with the one and only Joe Rogan
wrestling MMA his deepest questions in
the cosmos
[Applause]
[Music]